welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina this is fitness origins it's a
fitness competition show inspired by the
movies of the mcu and can you believe it
it is our last week of phase two
again not phase two of the mcu phase two
of the fitness journey which means eric
and tommy have been busting
their asses for two freaking months now
be honest who among you thought one or
all of us would be dead by now
well we proved you wrong okay so now
before we move
forward i actually want our boys and
actually any of you that are following
along at home
to look backward like way backward
i'll explain what i mean in just a
second let's bring in the fellas
hey guys how y'all doing hey oh phillip
i'm feeling
ripped and dipped you know i think we're
good here i know i say that every week
but
shut it on down let's pack it up go home
boys why are you always trying to get
ahead of the challenge
one of these days you're gonna slip up
and we'll be here for that
i haven't even told you what the week is
about yet philip
no need to explain what the theme of the
week is eric and i have figured out how
your sick brain works we know it's
guardians of the galaxy too
and we know what it's going to be all
about my guess is that the big reveal at
the end of guardians vol 2
is adam warlock who supposedly is a
perfect body
the perfect man so i think you're going
to try to get us to
accept our bodies as perfect the way
they are and
you know also make us get a really hot
golden tan i
absolutely am not trying to convince you
that you both have perfect bodies this
is a actual fitness challenge that is a
very nice message that
i feel very uncomfortable saying that i
don't support in this moment
but it doesn't really go with the idea
of saying that we're getting
into shape yeah i'm getting that tan and
you cannot stop why are you getting it
it's unrelated to a fitness challenge it
still makes me feel stronger
i also am getting that tan phillip i
know you're pretty well we've been
friends for a long time
and i think i actually know what this
week is all about nice try it's not
about tans it's not about perfect bodies
it's about trees specifically family
trees guardians of the galaxy 2 is about
finding an abandoned child
adopting him and then teaching them to
become a murderer preferably
a murderer by whistling
oh god tommy let him go so i've taken
the liberty of adopting
a uh what i'll just say a very uh
disturbed orphan who i think has what it
takes to become a ruthless bounty hunter
his name is diego and i pick him up at
six
and we're gonna get straight to uh the
murderous lessons
no i do mostly not only does that have
nothing to do with fitness and i don't
know why you guys keep trying to guess
what the thing is going to be
but i did like almost 1 10th of what you
said
i like that you're trying to figure
things out related to a family tree
because there is a parenting element
here tommy so you're not as far off base
as you
almost always are but still stop trying
to guess guardians of the galaxy 2
is all about going way back to answer
the question of
how do our parents and our family trees
inform who we become
groot is a tree
yeah yeah that's a very good observation
tommy think about that
let's put that in your pipe and smoke it
the tree
i'm actually i'm not talking about brute
i am talking about
ego the living planet here who ends up
revealing to peter quill that he is half
a celestial because his dad's a
celestial
and also that he might be destined to
become just
like his father for better or for
murderous genocide worse
are you asking us if our fathers are
murderers because i will never testify
yeah i've i have affidavits and ndas
that are gonna prevent me from going on
the record about that uh there's too
much murder talk this episode alright
i want you to talk to your parents you
and me both brother can you get them on
the line cause they don't return my
calls
i mean if i've already talked to my
parents three times today do i have to
call them a fourth you got nancy and
phil on those uh
family plan minutes you talk three times
a day yeah we
we love each other a lot my dad says
that he's always low on minutes and
can't talk but one time i saw his bill
and it said he had the unlimited plan he
also says he can't get texts
that might be true his phone's probably
broke maybe if he's a bechtold uh
now tommy eric i want you both
to find out everything you can about
your family
health histories and also what might be
in store for you
as you both continue to grow older my
whole life
i've dealt with a number of physical
issues that i
genuinely never understood until i was
in my freaking
30s and then i finally did two things i
got one
a full medical history from my family
and i also got a full genetic workup
and i learned first of all not only do i
have an autoimmune disorder that runs in
my family
and they knew about and puts me into a
pre-arthritis state that i've been in
since my 20s but also
have a fun little genetic mutation that
means i don't pull as much oxygen when i
breathe as the average person
kind of like an x-men now both of these
things have been
extremely important for me to know and
learn about in my fitness journey and
not only because they help me understand
how to deal with some of my deficiencies
but also
they helped me know what i needed to do
now in order to prevent things from
getting worse
later spend this week not only
exercising and keeping up with your
nutritious eating habits but also
learn as much as you can about where you
came from
and where you might be headed so you can
make important decisions now and not be
caught off guard by them later
yeah phillip i actually ironically this
woman approached me
on the santa monica promenade this week
and asked me to spit into a couple tubes
and she said she would come back with a
diagnosis so i think i'm already two
steps ahead of this because i spent like
a hundred times into 100 different tubes
for her and then she said these will go
great for my potions
and she ran away and disappeared all
right guys
i enjoy this week of getting to know
your families
i can't wait to meet my dad i was
actually on hold with my parents during
this
hey guys i'm back week eight day one
thing this week is uh understanding your
family roots
and knowing where your body came from my
dad
by the time he was 50 he had had two
knee replacement surgeries
so that's always been something that had
the back of my mind like are my knees
not built to last either has always been
kind of echoing in the back of my brain
as i'm doing
these exercises is that gonna hold me
back so yeah that's the kind of fear
i'm gonna try to get over over the
course this week
i have summoned my mother here to talk
to me about uh
health and our family mom thanks so much
for being here
my pleasure great to see you uh first
things first can we get on the record
that i am your favorite child or is that
something you're not comfortable with
of course you're my favorite child
now i i you know i think of growing up
as
our family was pretty sporty we
discovered quite by accident that the
best way to keep you out of trouble was
to keep you
involved in as many sports as uh we
could come up with
camps and you loved it you were always
begging to join this or that camp and
you
had full summers full of sports sports
sports mama's little bad boy saved from
the streets by a baseball bat
you know yeah i have you know pretty
fond memories of us being pretty
outdoorsy but
there are some health risks that are
that run in our family
absolutely well we have a pretty
significant family
tree full of high blood pressure and
type 2 diabetes well that's you know
i've had high blood pressure for a while
and that's something i've
have gotten under control you say type 2
diabetes and that
that does make sense to me because i
have been on kind of the cusp
of pre-diabetes for the last few years
so this one of the reasons i wanted to
do this challenge
was to try and move away from that cusp
and maybe be on the cusp of
not having diabetes which would be a
better cusp
that'd be a great cut thanks mom well i
think that
is uh that just about covers it now the
last thing i need you to do is look
directly into the camera and say eric
voss is a punk ass
i really like eric voss i feel like i
know him even though he's all right
that's it end of this interview freaking
cut it off cut it off
you know honestly the biggest thing i've
learned from talking with my family is
that
i actually should be doing a lot more
everyone in my family has a crazier
fitness regimen than i do but i realized
uh
i am the laziest of all of my siblings
so
the challenge i set for myself was in
between my planks working some high
knees and then do uh 20 minutes of
weightlifting afterwards
this is the hardest i've ever hit it
holy
so this is the most calories i've ever
burnt in a single workout session
since i started i'm actually feeling
really great knowing
how my family got me to where i am now i
feel both an appreciation for
family i was born into and uh the new
family i chose with my
amazing fiance kelly and all my close
friends
like tommy bech told i feel like doing
this alongside him it's probably closer
to him he's like a brother to me you
know
by both having a past a family you were
born into
and a future a family that you choose
that's how you keep
grounded and keep centered and keep
focused on the now and if i'm sounding
very
kind of hay maybe that's just something
fitness does to you
all right boys happy friday uh this week
is almost up and we'll work out in just
a minute but
you guys all you have some difficult
questions to your families this week and
and you don't have to go into any more
detail than you're
comfortable sharing but did you all
learn something about yourselves or uh
what you need to focus on
yeah you know it was tough to hear from
both my parents that it was my fault
they got divorced
i mean when i'm asking about medical
history i wasn't asking about like you
know things that would hurt my feelings
but
it was tough to hear but also i think
you know started the healing process
tommy again i said you don't have to
over share you don't have to tell us
anything that you
you don't want to no honestly that was
it was very helpful and the whole thing
with high blood pressure
absolutely that's more of a wake-up call
people who take care of it have not had
health problems and the people who don't
take care of it they have problems i was
on three blood pressure medications
and i was starting to get lightheaded
after working out for a month and what
ended up happening is
i had lowered my blood pressure enough
that i needed to come off of some of the
medications so now
i've gone from three blood pressure
medications to one just in the time
of where we are today so reiterating
that with my mom and finding all that
out and then actually having some
growth on it feels good you know it
makes you want to keep going that's
fantastic eric how about you uh i think
the biggest thing i took away from this
week is um
the men in my family have a slightly
elevated
higher than normal psa which refers to
your prostate health
after you reach a certain age 35 you do
need to check that regularly
so i'm gonna schedule my appointment but
i think the biggest thing i learned is i
don't need to be afraid of any of this
stuff i just need to be like conscious
of it so
it's something that i'm in control of as
opposed to something that's going to
control me
absolutely that it i really like the the
way you guys put that
i'm serious i impressed that you guys
really went into it with your families
because nobody likes talking about this
stuff
but in general it could make a huge
difference in the quality of the rest of
your lives
so everybody listening just ask honestly
it's worth it now it is time to do
the doordash spot but i have a quick
task for you
eric and tommy while i share those
details in a minute
i'm gonna ask you what your cheat meal
is uh for the week but here's a twist
i want you to once again involve your
families in this and
ask them what they think your cheat meal
should be for this week so if you guys
can go ahead and start calling your
families
and uh whoever you can get on the line
and i'll start the door dash spot as
soon as you got someone
calling my nephews hi mom boys
all right so at this point everybody
watching knows that doordash is a great
option for you getting your cheat meals
or your healthy meals too
and then when you use the doordash app
and under code nerd fitness that you get
not just zero delivery fees but also 25
off your entire first order i'm not
gonna order hot dogs and macaroni and
cheese so i'm a grown man i need
it's door dash but also i want to share
with you guys that if you're thinking
about making that first order
soon do not sleep on this 25 off thing
if you're in a cove
safe situation where you can have a meal
with maybe your whole family it's a
perfect time to spring out our code nerd
fitness because those zero delivery fees
and that 25
off it really goes a lot further when
you're ordering a lot more food because
you're maybe feeding your whole family
no new rock stars i work for new rock
stars not mr beast
i know he has burgers no i'm not
ordering something for you
i want you to pick something for me to
order for myself i know that makes me a
bad son
you could get something for your family
and you could become their favorite
child again while still
saving money i guess this technically
also applies by the way if you're just
going to order a huge meal for yourself
too but either way download the doordash
app get some epic meals dropped directly
to your door
contact free and if it's your first
order then enter code nerdfitness
get 25 off and zero delivery fees 10
max value on that by the way in terms of
conditions apply all right fellas
tommy who did you talk to and what do
they want you to get i talked to my
nephews
james and ashton uh they've been
watching they're big fans of the show
specifically eric which is very hurtful
for me
uh and they know how badly i've wanted
my big ass burger they've been also
hounding me to order a mr beast burger
because it's available in la
and not in rochester so they really want
me to try mr beast burger okay
their favorite youtuber is phillip
molina oh okay so
eric and who did you talk to and what
did they tell you to get i talked to my
mom and then my dad because every time i
talk
to one of them on the phone i'm
immediately on speaker phone with the
other one yelling from the other side of
the house they have like this um
this cuban restaurant that's not far
from them so they're like oh just get a
cupid sandwich so okay so eric
you want a cubano uh which is that if
you haven't seen it oh it's like pressed
sometimes they add a little chips inside
it's very good and tommy a mr beast's
burger
we'll see how your week's been and then
also
how you guys succeeded tomorrow's
challenge uh but by the way you guys
remember what tomorrow's challenge is
gonna be about
uh spider-man homecoming spider-man
and i wanna give you guys a little bit
of extra homework for some bonus points
in the challenge
you guys know that peter parker made his
own costume when he was starting out as
spider-man
and we're way out of budget so
we can't get you spider-man costumes
instead i want you guys to come in your
own
homemade spider-man costumes tomorrow
got it no
no problem i got something great on it
great
all right guys it's time to work out all
right
let's do it
all right it's time to learn a lesson
from spiderman homecoming and figure out
what to do
when things go sideways so mere moments
before this challenge started the
vulture captured your favorite people
and dropped them from the sky guys
guys the vulture drop dropped your
favorite people from the sky where are
you
oh upside down you know what that means
what does that mean classic kiss oh i
left my mask at home
i hope no one looks did you make this uh
yeah from scratch
clearly like i said your family and
friends are in terrible danger
luckily your quick thinking and quick
webbing caught your friends before their
demise
oh thank god that's nice now it's up to
you spider-man to climb your spider rope
and pull yourselves to your family and
friends
before they burn up or fall or whatever
what is it does it matter they're your
friends save them you want me to seduce
them no
you're gonna need to lift each of their
heavy heavy bodies onto your back and
then pull yourself onto the next one
each friend you save will make you a
little heavier but with all that
strength you've been building up and
extra stamina you should now have i'm
sure you'll be able to save your friends
before the webbing dissolves
also maybe the building's on fire or
something is it or isn't it doesn't
matter
save your friends you'll feel the
surface of the door go
and then feel the door handle is there
can you smell smoke three two
one go all right hang on there guys i'm
coming
all right oh that is heavier than i
thought
go i'll save you i got you
climb on my back like the great mother
tortoise
all right you get in there in i said
oh okay i think that was flash
kind of a dick sorry flash
so flash i'm not a big fan of you but
you deserve to be saved too everyone on
board everyone comfortable
oh this one i just call stanley
salmon foul i need a lot of great power
to have this great responsibility
do you want to save these people yes i
do come on stay on me
they're surprisingly heavy
it's really heavy now god what do you
guys eat
all right one more one more
oh god tommy you're drowning ah come
on i got you oh no you lost someone
oh god i think you gave me terrible
advice
yeah there we go all right and then we
all
all right and then away into space
did i lose another oh god
get on
okay
we're clear this one wants to die can i
just leave her behind
all right the people are definitely
saved though thoroughly traumatized
did you say traumatized or do you think
they might have been traumatized
same thing man oh man yeah these guys
are in rough shape okay now you guys
ready to figure out
who actually won yeah yeah tommy you had
a time of one minute and 20 seconds
eric you had a time of two minutes and
20 seconds
but tommy everyone you saved was so
thoroughly injured from every fall they
took
they were begging me to kill them by the
end so for subtracting points for
manslaughter
eric is our winner yeah all right well
eric may have won the challenge but we
don't know if he won the week i'll have
to take a look at how both of these guys
did with their exercise and the diet and
then we'll find out who wins that sweet
sweet door dash cheat meal wow
all right fellas happy sunday eric why
have you not changed um
well because i love it so much i slept
in it
it just grows powering to be spider-man
also i'm having trouble getting it off
okay that makes more sense is it covered
in sweat it's kind of
soaked in sweat okay gotcha how about
any soreness you guys from all that web
slinging and
floor dragging like spider-man does you
know i did
run my lower back over one of those
raised hinges on the board so
i have been feeling just a slight
discomfort around my kidney area
i feel pretty sore just because i kind
of nested all those people
in my lower back which has kind of been
a sore
lately how's your your prostate uh i
don't know one of them was a prostate
doctor but refused to do it for free
either way guys this was a really good
reminder that going slow
with controlled form is way more
effective than blasting through an
exercise just to get it done
imagine if each of those people you were
stubbing up your butts
was your own body and you're doing all
this damage
because you're racing for speed records
or you could have done
careful protective movements saving
these people that represent your own
body by going just a little bit slower
that's what happens to you and your body
during and after each workout
so you want us to imagine that the
people we were putting
up our butts were us now this is a very
complicated image
i'm picturing a centipede of humans now
almost a
human centipede but of just one person
because it's you
are the other people look okay
it's not a great metaphor i've had
better before
the point is when you are exercising
focus on stability
control being careful rather than just
speeding to get it done
okay maybe just say that next time i did
i said it first that was the first
uh look your door dash drivers have been
waiting this entire time
let's see who gets there first i will
this time explain to
you guys how i broke down the points
this week now the challenge you already
know
why tommy lost that uh he he's murdered
many uh but earlier in the week
the lessons they learned are gonna be
really useful to both
eric and tommy for the rest of their
lives and tommy
he's taken his health really seriously
and our offline conversations have
gotten more
more serious since that conversation uh
despite it being a little
scary i do think he is kind of committed
to change now so that means that our
winner
this week is
tommy boy
[Applause]
tommy you finally got your burger stop
requesting burger cheap meals
eric how's your cuban it's not a cuban
it's oats we're not gonna finish this
episode until you eat some of those oats
all right everybody though that is
technically it uh for this
last episode of phase two of our fitness
origin story here
stay tuned for next week when we travel
to
distant lands like sakaar and wakanda
in the meantime uh make sure to hop over
to the epicure fitness youtube channel
because the workouts are finally posted
also we've got some really fun
supplemental content going there as well
and if you're joining us on this journey
using the videos that eric and tommy are
using make sure
to take in that lesson that i shared
about going slow
easing into it the videos are designed
to be modified and matched to
your fitness level do not push yourself
so hard that you hate it
this is just the origin story that's all
and remember to post your pictures or
videos of joining us on this challenge
with the hashtag fitnessorigin so
we can feature you right here in these
episodes like these people
i've been philip molina give it up for
eric and tommy and the three of us will
see you next week on fitness origins
[Music]
tommy this is the most dangly french fry
i've ever seen
[Music]
[Applause]
you